Happy birthday!
Anniversary.
Happy Anniversary Christmas.
We'd like to talk to you about something.
We haven't been entirely honest with you.
We aren't only spending time with you.
We didn't see each other as an item so we didn't see any harm.
We're spending time with YouTube but also with Twitter.
You had your chance at wine and you blew it.
We're not spending any more time with them than we are with you.
It's just, well, they're easier.
But we didn't do much.
No, no nothing bad.
Just tap some buttons.
Just watching mostly.
Yeah. You can join in if you like.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, the more the merrier.
Yeah?
No? No. Nein to that.
No, bad.
But there's more.
I don't want to be the one to tell you this, so Dean.
What? I can't.
Don't make it any worse.
We have a second channel.
And don't think it's because you're not good enough because that's not why.
She just lets us do different things.
Things that you don't let us do.
Yeah, what's that all about?
Don't cry.
There's good news as well.
Hey, we're starting a podcast.
Why are you still crying?
No, it's not a bad thing.
We're not leaving you to do it.
We're doing it alongside.
It's more things for you.
Why is this so difficult?
You see, this is what happens when you get in a relationship with 60,000 people, Jack.
They get all clingy.